hello everybody welcome to let's play
slender claustrophobia haha okay I know
I'm late on this but I was doing this
got released on as soon as I was doing
my livestream I actually have still have
no idea my
how did I get here I can't remember I
must have blacked out I need to get out
of here I need to go I have the worst
feeling that something something is
following me oh oh oh no oh no find the
real key out of ten its amazed ah no
that's wrong no well well we're boned
well we're gonna die this I can
guarantee you now this is not gonna be
one that I complete OOP donor board
donor board a little it hello hello
everybody hi ah yeah what else is here I
like it I like this Oh what thought what
uh interesting well here's the exit this
is obviously where I'm going to come
back to now this is a new take this is a
new take on different game mechanic well
not different game mechanic but
different style at least and I can
definitely appreciate them trying to do
that so I like the open environment as
well all I'm gonna get so lost in here
this is the worst this is got to be the
worst ever that icky up Wow
I found a Kia now will I not get the
real key until I until I
get all ten or will I randomly get one
and then have to just deal yeah do I
have to keep trying each one I get or
are they not gonna spawn or what's the
dealio oh this is gonna be impossible
oh my Oh in there nope okay don't get
caught in the dead ends that for damn
sure there's a building over there let
me go over there let me go over there to
that building over there and then over
there too maybe hey how do I get in that
building over there the awning oh come
on don't be like that
bubeleh nothing okay maybe maybe I do
have to go test out this key so let me
go run or just a jaunt just a nice
relaxing raw oh hello
pink two keys let's try these two keys I
was thinking that it was gonna be like
you didn't have to do or you had to get
to get one and then try it and then come
back and get another thankfully it's not
that way is that place where I got the
first key I think that is so I'm looking
for these pedestal type devices
I actually surprisingly given that I
haven't I'm a little late I haven't seen
anything on this like the other ones
I've actually avoided any screenshots of
it so I had no idea it was gonna be a
maze we can trap Donna
only to chance of Slendy encounter is
minimal bring it on bring it on Slendy
you ain't got nothing on me I've beat
you the last two times I don't see why I
can't beat you now ah cow how do I get
over there I know where I'm going on
home towards that wall is where I need
to be for the door ah here we go finally
goodness gracious that is a serious maze
like they're not joking around
wrong key used did you tried both of
them no darn you all right I'm assuming
that you're gonna need to grab all ten
keys before you can make your way I'm
it's kind of cool that they're adding
more and more stuff each time they do
like the voice actor adding a voice
actor in is really cool and just a nice
little subtle touches like that they're
improving each time they do it which is
very good ah number four oh yeah
I'm gonna get this on my first try yeah
ahahaha that was Slendy that was trendy
Slendy you know that was not render man
slender so this it's a statue
maybe it's an obelisk so that I can find
my bearing probably okay this isn't I
think that's the one I was at earlier
that's a new one dot being one the
problem is there's so many nooks and
crannies oh my goodness I haven't even
reached the other end of the maze and
we're already six minutes in I mean oh
oh this is gonna kill me nothing worse
in worst game ever but I'm gonna have
the worst time just try to find
everything in here haha I didn't see
anything
haha what the hell was that all about
okay let me go give you
oh I don't know okay that's good
I don't know about that anything down
there okay nothing oh I'm gonna get
children please be off oh yes why oh my
oh my goodness
oh my oh howdy-hi right now without a
gun is all up on me maybe I have the
right key maybe I gotta go try it now oh
I can't spread for jet maybe I have the
right key maybe I do seems to be all up
in my grill
so maybe I'm the right one okay dark
go get our hello your dog on there don't
you dare there's just so many corners
right
ah no let's try oh I don't even know I
don't even know how he was he was all
over me
I was following all the rules ah you're
getting what you deserve you're even
when he so you're oh well I do I should
note on it Slendy oh boy
man he was like right there good the
donators did not help well I Matthew
stringer how did I get here
I can't remember I must have blacked out
I must find I need to get out of here I
need to get out of here I have the worst
feeling that something something
slowly peaceful oh I don't like this
okay I'm just gonna fall a sort of
circle pattern see if I can do something
about this but man he was all over me at
five Keys like holy crap there was just
about nothing that I could have done
I mean why I need to save my run juice
because apparently he's gonna be all
over me and there's not a darn thing I
can do about that Fricker fracker oh man
he was just like who turned corner slide
night turn corner good turn corner I
don't see a bunny behind me just bad
news he's a bad bad Slendy ah
ergo frisky okay ah dead end um phoned
I'm boned already it was gonna be like
the work of the world's first one out of
ten death oh god I'm gonna do I'm an
idiot
what am i doing what am I doing with my
life what am I doing with my life uh I
play video game for a living
ah actually that's pretty life
Oh already already I am so bored uh or
if I walk backwards
now what if I walk backwards through the
mouth we gonna do now lady
oh are you go spawn behind me or in
front of me side Oh
who put the patch there's a puppy mmm me
grumpy oh I'm already at the other end
to the frickin map and I haven't even
found a second one oh god I'm so I'm so
dead I'm so dead I'm not even find a
second one I'm so dead I'm so dead I'm
gonna try this key cuz I haven't got
anything better to do oh oh no not a
circle not a circle I'm so bad oh the
world worth 110 death oh I'm going in a
circle Ken this is it's a big circle
this is a circle this is a circle this
is a circle oh it's a circle it's a
circle it's a circle give me Alliser any
other circum thank you thank you
thinking evening I'm not going to that
way cuz I was the way out of circle how
is this happening to me
I was so good I was good at Slenderman
Slenderman shadow is the name of this
series by the way markstein's a great
guy
you guys all if you get a chance please
donate cuz he's doing a great job with
these maps I'm just bad at mazes I'm I
can't draw the map inside my head while
I'm wandering through I know where I am
I'm at the northern tip of the area but
I just I can't find a second one
anywhere I'm so pathetic I'm gonna walk
right in as Lenny oh I'm so pathetic I'm
so pathetic come on where's another one
give me another one Oh
ah OOP ah door dagnabbit
I think Slenderman thought I was so
pathetic they just try to leave
God spare me more oh not again
oh good god maybe under this awning
there will be another one oh it's not
gonna get me to the awning because it's
gonna be another battle right here I get
guy can see it but kick into it little
big baby nope no oh oh you think you can
get another one markiplier but you so
wrong Oh God okay here's another awning
can I get a second key yeah oh thank you
so much Niall now I won't die with one
of ten at least at least that time that
is good that is good that is good I
found a key and it was good I'll never
find another this is my key there are
many like it but this one is mine I am
nothing without my key just as my key is
nothing without me here's another awning
oh man sues the eye it would take me a
long time to learn the patterns of this
force
nope but here's the door so let me give
it a try
maybe mammy you never know oh I don't
think it's that way I think yeah wrong
key oh I just got a shiver I just got a
chill down my spine
hello donators you didn't do anything
for me last time but maybe you can help
out again this is back where I started
I think unless I started in a random spy
I don't think I did
that's right in that book I don't know I
don't know I'm just having the worst
luck ah I was wondering where you were I
was wondering it's so good of you to
stop by I'll get you some tea oh I know
lucky mark no likey golly
hahaha I know slender man's gonna bop
around a corner I just know he is I know
he is cuz that's how he be oh yay oh no
I've been here before this is my second
one you gotta be kidding me that's no
that's impossible
Oh God Oh No give me a third one please
it's so sad this is so sad uh-oh is it
when they're Oh
ah I'm not so terrible after all I'm
starting to learn that there's no point
in walking around the outside
you basically have to break it up into
sections there are sections it's hard to
tell but there are sections here ah the
sections and I'm willing to bet that
there are like two to three keys per
quadrant of the mouth and you had asked
out each one at each time so like
walking around the outside probably not
such a beneficial idea but then there is
something to don't like this so that you
have to wow I saw that No
Oh dead ant dead ant dead ant dead ant
dead ant done a 10 a 10 a 10 yeah your
name's Lea I can't smile
I didn't see your slim be probably dead
end probably nothing probably nothing
right it's not a key not a key
huh so much worse than nothing I would
have liked nothing Oh God uh-huh look
away oh why don't why we're going what
is he doing what is he doing to me I
don't even know there's a dog in my room
right now I didn't even know you're
there
Oh Oh give me another one I don't wanna
die at 4:00 or vibe oh just give me ten
and then kill me just give me ten give
me false hope and then kill me destroy
me
whoa don't get dark don't get dark get
away do it buddy oh I got God I know
yeah I know your uh get away get away
get away are you right behind back are
you you're getting dark
Ida getting dark oh oh I can't do this
one I can't do it I can't do it
aah oh how did he get me how oh I'm
curious like I use getting dark of
running oh no could I have done what
else could I have done what else what
else could I have done what else could I
have done all right okay so I'm gonna
cut it here man this is a tough one this
is a tough one
if someone has any tips if someone drew
out a map if somebody thinks I'm
terrible please write in the comments
below because by oh I'm not doing well
on this one so thank you all so much for
watching please let me know in the
comments if you wanted to try it again
of all these ones I feel like I did the
worst in this one so if you want to try
this one again please let me know in the
comments below so thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye